foreign
Jeff is with us Jeff's in Springfield
Missouri hi Jeff how are you
I'm doing all right thanks for taking my
call Dave sure what's up I I over the
last five years I took an
um I lost my job and took a pay cut of
about fifty thousand dollars
um I've since in the last year I've
brought my income back to where I was
before this happened but over the last
five years
I've also had a failing business and I
built up quite a bit of credit card debt
um 110 000 my wife and I we make about a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars a
year but we have a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in credit card debt
between the business and ourselves and
we're strapped I and would contemplating
bankruptcy looking at all of our options
or doing what we can do with
your every dollar plan on the budget
things like that but we've quite frankly
just started that and I'm just looking
for some older advice
uh 52 years old what kind of business
was it it's been a rough
it was a house flipping business
you got any of them left
um in the middle of one right now but
it's I mean it's out of all the houses
we've done this has been the worst house
and
it's eating Us Alive
you'll make a profit on it when you flip
it
Maybe
a little I mean what do you owe on it
510 we owe about 115 and it's probably
worth 140 to 150. yeah when's it going
on the market
hopefully in the next week or so good
what do you own your home
I owe three hundred thousand dollars
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars we've built it about 18 years
ago and have a lot of Sweat Equity in it
okay so of the 115 000 income you told
us is that your wife I'm assuming or do
you have an A or is this you said you
got a new good job okay right no I've
got a my job is is really good
um pays well my wife
works and does does well also
um for this area so over overall
flipping houses you have lost when all
the smoke cleared 110 000.
between that and then my job my salary I
mean we were living on credit cards for
a while
okay all right so but the bottom line
was you the overall business model of
flipping houses you lost money on it
and mainly that's been in the last two
years since covet okay and this this
house has really been a disaster yeah
okay all right
so and how old did you say you were
again 52 you said yeah okay yeah
um
the good news is you're not bankrupt the
bad news is
um
you're you're scared and you're beat up
absolutely
and when we're scared and when we're
beat up
uh we tend to make
uh we have more of a tendency to make
bad decisions because we're kind of in a
fog you're in the forest can't see the
trees kind of thing been there myself I
know how it feels it's it's hard to
think clear because everything's just
overwhelming you this idea of just
surviving
does that sound familiar
absolutely yeah
okay
so this is going to
um
hurt your feelings and hurt your wife's
feelings even more
but uh you can pay the credit card debt
you just gotta sell your house
I don't understand that and here's the
bad news I don't know the rule in
Missouri but in every state except Texas
and Florida you can't keep this much
equity in bankruptcy
because what happens is they they have a
homestead exemption when you file
Chapter 7 bankruptcy there's a homestead
exemption which is the amount of your
Equity that you get to keep
and anything above that that's
substantial they're going to force the
sale of the house to pay your creditors
so you might as well pay them
so are you behind on the credit cards
no we are current we've called them and
got reduced monthly payments and good
we've canceled all the credit cards good
um so what I would do having been
through what you're going through except
with zeros on the end and I was 28 I
wasn't 52 but I still remember being so
freaking scared I couldn't breathe
what I would do if I were you is I would
fight like a wild man to not have to
sell my house
let's pre let's pretend you pay a bunch
of credit cards late over the next
three years
and it messes up your credit but you
become debt free except the house
I would do that
and by the way 115 000 income thirty
thousand a year you can do for three
years forty thousand a year for three
years you can do it on 115 000 income
you got no life but you get to keep your
house no life during that three years
and you're probably gonna be working
extra doing something else well that's
and you're going to be selling
everything you can get your hands on
including this junkie butt house you're
getting ready to get rid of
Jeff how much time ballpark are you
spending per week on this house it's
almost gone yeah
how many hours beyond your work are you
spending on this flip house
probably 25 hours a week all right so
today's Point here I'm trying to give
you some hope I agree with Dave I I get
rid of that house quickly as possible
and now we're done with that and now
that 25 hours I've been spinning on that
sinkhole I'm gonna spend the 25 hours
because you're pretty handy guy you
could pick up some really nice pain work
with your skills true or false
um yes the answer is true to inside
hustles I know my point is listen you
either do that or you sell your house
yeah and I'd keep the house yeah work
the extra 25 hours and pay that hustle
my way through this and pay 40 or 50 000
a year on this debt and be done with it
in two two and a half years that's my
plan
okay
that that's what I how I'd get after
that and and so the good so here's the
thing we just said there's two possible
paths
that's not bankrupt and by the way
bankrupt won't work you're going to lose
your house
in bankruptcy they're going to take it
and pay your creditors because you don't
you have so much Equity unless I'm wrong
I don't know again off the top of my
head you could ask what home Google you
can do it as soon as you get off I could
do it live if I had you know I run
Google but Google Google what the home
homestead exemption for Missouri is but
I'm betting you that it's you know
probably 10 20 30 grand something like
that and you got three you got a 200
Grand
it's it's 15 and I would have to go
chapter 13. yeah well you're not chapter
13 is you chapter 13 is a payment plan
and you pay the creditors
I know and so we'll just pay them you
got this Jeff even if you pay them late
chapter 13 destroys your credit paying
them late destroys your credit whoopee
destroy your credit who gives a crap
we're talking about bankruptcy here
talking about you keeping your house
we're talking about you turning the
corner on this chat putting this chapter
of your life that sucks in the rear view
mirror
so me the path I'm taking I'm gonna work
like a maniac for the next three years
I'm gonna get rid of this stupid house
in the next 30 days even if I break even
on it so I can get my life back and then
I'm gonna tear into these credit cards
working the death snowball smallest to
largest and you're not bankrupt you just
got a sucky two and a half years coming
up to put this crap in the rear of your
mirror and you can do it hang on we're
gonna sign you up for Financial Peace
University we're going to pay for it and
Jeff been where you are man I know how
it feels to be scared I can hear it in
your voice you call me anytime we'll
help you we'll encourage you we'll yell
at you we'll cheer for you whatever it
takes to keep you moving man